être étudiant c'est hyper ennuyeux voire
chiant est chef d'entreprise s'est pas
beaucoup mieux c'est compliqué mais par
contre être étudiant entrepreneur c'est
génial alors moi j'ai commencé une
formation à la fac je me suis retrouvé
dans quelque chose de très théorique et
très vite j'ai eu besoin de concret de
professionnalisation et je me suis dit
quel est le meilleur alibi que je puisse
trouver sans avoir à arrêter mes études
parce que c'est pas joli sur un cv c'est
pas rassurant pour les parents non plus
mais pour que je puisse faire quelque
chose qui me plaisent et finalement je
me suis dit peut-être que si je
m'intéresse un sujet sans avoir
l'ambition de devenir expert tout
l'experte en tant que tel mais une
experte avoir un petit plus des
connaissances en plus dans un domaine
ça pourrait peut-être m'apporter quelque
chose on se dit pas du jour au lendemain
on veut devenir entrepreneur on veut
devenir chef d'entreprise c'est pas
possible n'y a pas deux il ya pas de
manuels pour ça mais c'est un changement
de vie complètement progressif au début
ça se traduit par des rencontres
donc on va rencontrer des gens qu'on
n'aurait jamais pu croiser on aurait
jamais eu l'opportunité de croiser dans
notre vie scolaire dans notre vie
étudiante
on va commencer à travailler à avoir des
livrables un peu plus concret à pouvoir
avoir une expérience très différente de
celle des autres étudiants avec qui on
fait nos cours et puis on n'échappe pas
si facilement à la fac donc on y
retourne side je serais intéressé aux
courses et pas forcément simple et on
s'aperçoit que c'est pas si différent
non plus que de notre quotidien
d'entrepreneurs on a même un regard très
très différent sur ce qu'on a
l'opportunité de voir en cours c'est à
dire que un exercice avec des chiffres
mais on se projette avec notre
entreprise ont dit ah mince ça j'en
avais besoin
et on est une sorte d'auto formation
l'entrepreneuriat c'est à dire que ça me
permettrait avec les gens qui
m'intéresse dans les domaines qui
m'intéressent de pouvoir aussi
avoir une expérience qui me permet de me
dire est-ce que l'année prochaine je
m'oriente et versa versa et au final de
m mes études au service de mon
entreprise
essai de l'application ultra concrètes
avoir une entreprise à 19 ans on a
souvent l'idée un peu le cliché du
startup heures à la cool dans son canap
avec un sweat casque est en train de
bosser sur son mac c'est pas tout à fait
faux non plus c'est pas tout à fait vrai
on a énormément de liberté mais ça veut
aussi dire qu'on doit être autonome on a
des nouvelles responsabilités
mais ça veut aussi dire qu'on fait ce
qu'on veut et les les personnes avec qui
on a l'occasion de travailler qui ont
des carrières un petit peu plus
classique souvent nous regardent
différemment et souvent ça attire
beaucoup de bienveillance et on se
retrouve assez vite
ambassadeur de quelque chose d'une idée
d'une image parfois malgré nous c'est
pas toujours simple aussi de rester
quelqu'un de 19 ans quand on a une
entreprise on ne peut pas faire la fête
pareil on a d'autres préoccupations de
savoir avec qui on sort le jeudi soir
c'est très très particulier où on voit
les autres partir en vacances alors que
nous on a pas forcément de vacances mais
à côté de ça on voit aussi que l'on
arrive à intéresser des gens qu'on
arrive à devenir un peu quelqu'un
d'autre alors ça nous change pas mais
c'est des opportunités qui viennent à
nous et qui nous permettent de devenir
un peu plus qui on veut être
je pense que si si je suis venu à la fac
en économie-gestion c'est parce que je
cherchais un peu ma voix j'étais à la
recherche d'un sens qu'elles sont je
voulais donner à ma carrière
pourquoi je voulais travailler avec
quelle valeur pour qui et on devient
entrepreneur à partir du moment où on a
trouvé un sens et on peut se dire
aujourd'hui dans ma journée je veux
faire telle chose pour tel besoin parce
que ça me fait plaisir d'être avec ces
personnes là c'est des gens que j'admire
avec qui j'aurai travaillé
j'aurais rêvé de travailler avec
et au final on se met presque à leur
niveau et c'est un peu un vecteur très
très valorisant pour un jeune de 19 ans
qu'on va plus regarder du coup comme un
étudiant mais mais comme un chef
d'entreprise c'est un moyen de devenir
qui qui on veut être alors on peut voir
ça aussi beaucoup plus simplement en
disant entreprendre à 19 ans c'est mieux
parce qu'on n'a pas de boulot à quitter
ça peut se camoufler dans un cv il n'a
pas d'enfant à charge n'a pas vraiment
une vie hyper hyper rempli avec
énormément de responsabilités d'adulte
et et quand on sait qu'en france
l'âge moyen du créateur d'entreprise ses
38 ans on se dit mais comment des gens
peuvent attendre 20 ans avant de vouloir
donner un sens à ce qu'ils veulent faire
de leurs journées au final on passe
beaucoup plus de temps à travailler dans
une journée que s'occuper de notre vie
personnelle et si l'entrepreneuriat
c'était pas un moyen de faire ce qui
nous plaît et on y passera sans doute
plus de temps qu'un 35 heures 15 50
heures que n'importe quoi mais c'est
même plus du travail et je suis ni
étudiante ni entrepreneuse j'ai juste
des choses qui me plaisent qui me
permette de devoir des actions arrivée
par un entrepreneuriat si on si on s'y
consacrent vraiment c'est c'est vraiment
un retour immédiat aussi sur le temps
qu'on y passe et voir tout un tas de
choses qu'on pensait impensable et les
concrétiser grâce à un profil grâce à un
attrait pour un domaine c'est quand même
merveilleux or tout n'est pas simple
aussi quand il faut choisir ses études
en a beaucoup qui se réorientent il ya
les études ya aussi une part de risque
par des ce que je fais les bonnes études
ce que je me trompe
est-ce que j'ai choisi la bonne voie si
je rate ma licence j'ai redoublé
est-ce que ça va être comment on
explique sur un cv qu'on a passé sept
ans à avoir une licence c'est pas
possible
ben si c'est possible parce que
l'entrepreneuriat aussi c'est pas
évident ça veut pas dire qu'on va pas se
tromper
moi même j'ai commencé à 18 ans du coup
j'allais sur mes 19
j'ai travaillé sept mois sur un projet
que j'ai dû abandonner parce qu'on m'a
dit que c'était trop ambitieux que
j'étais tout seul que j'étais trop jeune
qu'en face de moi bah il y avait des
concurrents beaucoup trop important et
ça m'a appris à me remobiliser à
vraiment me dire est-ce que c'était du
temps perdu non c'était du temps investi
qui me permettent de faire autre chose
et en fait ce n'était qu'une étape vers
un autre projet qui lui se concrétiser
et qui est en train de réussir donc à
aucune fin en soi que ça soit dans les
études ou l'entrepreneuriat et dans les
deux cas il faut savoir prendre des
risques pour avoir un parcours peut-être
un peu plus atypiques faut pas avoir
peur des différents et je suis sûr
qu'aujourd'hui alors qu'on doit chercher
un
alors qu'on doit chercher un stage où
quelque chose on un coup de fil je peux
je peux trouver un stage peut avoir des
choses peut-être plus pertinente par mon
expérience face à un recruteur parce que
j'ai fait des actions qu'ils veulent
dire
ben moi ça c'est mes domaines d'intérêt
concrètement je sais faire ça maintenant
parce que j'ai les faits et j'ai pas
attendu qu'on me donne l'opportunité de
le faire donc c'est une question de
chance
on a parlé tout à l'heure mais c'est
aussi une question de l'opportunité et
la chance comme les opportunités je
pense que ce sont des choses qui se
provoque
si vous devez vraiment retenir quelque
chose de de ce site entrevue
ça serait que et a pas d'âge il n'y a
pas de profil type pour faire ce que
vous voulez et c'est pas parce que vous
avez passé cinq dix vingt ans à faire
quelque chose qui ressemble pas du tout
à un de vos futurs projets que vous
n'êtes pas capable de le faire c'est pas
parce que vous n'avez pas une licence en
marketing que vous n'êtes pas capables
de vendre quelque chose c'est pas parce
que vous n'avez pas fait un master en
finance que vous allez jamais comprendre
des tableaux excel super agaçant donc il
n'y a aucune fin en soi et surtout le
plus important c'est d'oser se lancer
quand vous êtes prêts
[Applaudissements]